uh thank you again and uh welcome to uh
Bean culture webinar series uh my name
is Chad
Schwarz um I'm an application scientist
uh in the cation division at Beckman
culture here uh in
Indianapolis um today we are excited to
um introduce Dr Osman barar who is an
assistant professor of Material Science
and Engineering at k Abdullah University
of Science and
Technology Dr barar received a
Bachelor's of science uh from
MIT in 2003 and went on and received a
ma Masters of Science and PhD in Applied
Physics from Harvard University in
2009 today our webinar will cover the
physical and chemical characterization
of nanoparticle constructs using the
Beckman cter analytical Ultra cuge so
without further Ado I would like to hand
over uh the slides and control to Dr
Osman Bard thank you um uh thanks Chad
for the introduction uh thank you all
for coming over here today to attend the
webinar my name is Osman backer and I'm
here to tell you about how to
characterize nanoparticle constructs
using the analytical ultra
cuge um my talk is divided into three
parts in the first part I'm going to be
telling you uh about the challenges of
analyzing nanop particles uh
particularly because they have
heterogeneous partial specific volumes
and uh and how to how to solve that
problem and then I'm going to be telling
you about a general method that was
recently developed uh using a software
package to uh to directly uh fit
nanoparticle size distributions this
method is called the custom grid method
that that was developed by Boris demer
and then finally I'm going to conclude
my talk by discussing some experimental
considerations one should think about in
order to avoid uh artifacts in measuring
nanop
particles um I'd like to thank Beckman
culture's analytical Auto certification
team for inviting me to this webinar and
I'd like to also uh thank boy demer for
providing some of the slides with the
custom grid
method um before going further I would
like to conduct a a
poll to uh figure out the background of
the audience
so uh the the first uh the first poll
and and please do part take a minute to
participate um asks whether uh asks
about if you're familiarity with the
analytical alter centrifuge so canly
just uh answer the question so we could
uh um get an idea about the background
of of the
users
okay
um
so okay
so I I guess we got the response from
most people and looks like about 2third
of you are uh novices and U um maybe
about 10% are very experienced users and
and about
20% uh are somewhat familiar with that
with culture centrifuge my my second my
second question is um what is your
experience with the nanop particles have
you used them uh before in your research
and do you plan to or do you plan to use
them in your research
okay okay so it looks like
uh so it looks like uh most of you are
familiar with nanop particles
and um finally I just like to uh ask the
following question what method do you
use typically to what is the primary
method that you use to
analyze uh your nanop particles so we
have uh electron microscopy analytical
centrifugation Dynamic light
scattering field flow for acation G
electropheresis and we have mass
spectroscopy or if none of the
above so
uh it looks like most of you uh use
electrom microscopy in Dynamic light
scattering and some of you have been
using analytical ex fation and other
methods um so uh in in general it seems
to me that uh many of you are new to
analytic igation particularly to nanop
particles so I'm going to start off uh
slow and and try to uh take the topic
from the
beginning um all right
so
um just before I start i' I'd like to
introduce some uh useful references uh
on on the topic so uh these four papers
uh are are very useful uh for anyone
interested in studying nanoparticle with
the analytical entri huge um the first
paper is is by stachi and myself and it
covers the uh how to use analytical
certification to solve a partial
specific volume of of uh nanop particles
the second paper is uh in just published
recently in analytical Chemistry by
borice demler and uh it it covers a
general method and software package that
that one can use to anal analyze the
distributions directly of Nano particles
and then I also recommend um a recent
paper in ACS Nano by puert and uh Waban
and culen where they uh highlight some
new methodologies uh to to study nanop
particles especially in terms of
instrumentation and then um I'd also
recommend a very good uh review
published in 2010 by plankin and culin
that covers uh nanoparticles and uh
generally gives an idea uh to beginners
of what are the challenges when studying
nanop
particles okay so um first off I'm going
to uh discuss about the challenges in
studying nanop particles and uh how to
how to Sol how to solve
them um so
for uh for those of you who are not
familiar with nanop particles nanop
particles are typically are a composite
um material uh typically containing a
core that's inorganic and a shell that's
organic usually we have to use a um
multiple modalities of methods to
analyze the uh the different parts of
the nanop particle so for example uh the
overall particle diameters typic
typically can people use Dynamic light
scattering or Fiel flow fractionation
maybe G electropheresis
while for the particle core people would
use electron microscopy or mass
spectroscopy and then uh one has to uh
combine many methods in a global
analysis to figure out what's going on
with the nanop particle but that's
actually uh quite different to do
because nanop particles not only have a
diameter variation but they also have
density variation because uh as the
particle size changes also does the
ratio between the organic component and
the shell and the inorganic component in
the core
okay um now uh so so what that means is
that you have a hetrogeneous size
distribution that's very difficult to
analyze with a global method and so we
need a single method that can analyze
both size and density variation at the
same time so the question is how can we
measure size mass and density
distributions in nanop
particles now I'm going to since most of
you uh uh have used electron microscopy
and life scattering to uh study
nanoparticles I'm going to just
highlight some of the shortcomings of of
these methods uh first off if you're
going to use electron microscopy your uh
nanop particles have a typically have an
inorganic core and organic shell electr
microscopy is is very is it's very
difficult to uh image the organic shell
with the electrom microscopy because of
the low mass uh of of the Organics so
typically electromicroscopy is only
useful for the study the core and
moreover because of particle size
counting typically your sample size is
you know a few tens to a few hundreds of
particles and because you're looking at
the projection of the particle in a
two-dimensional plane you end up um you
end up with a with a significant sizing
error and perhaps a misrepresentation of
your particle so for example here we
have a atomically monodispersed particle
but because it's on the on the electr
microscopy grid uh in in different
orientations it seems as if uh this
particle has a size distribution when in
fact it's one single
species
finally uh if you're using light
scattering you know you can imagine that
the biggest particles in in your size
distribution typically dominate but also
for um size distributions that are less
than 10 nanometers it's it's almost
impossible to get any uh Mass
information okay um analytical ALR
centrifugation uh seems like a in a very
ideal method to study uh nanop particles
um you know for those of you who don't
know what an analytical cuge is in simp
the simplest terms imagine you have a
distribution you have two you have two
component system of nanop particles or
or an arbitrary number of components in
a uh in in solution and so if you
subject them to a
gravitational uh force field then
they're going to sediment at different
rates and if you can monitor this
sedimentation process with a with
somehow optically or uh or or any other
way then you could actually uh follow
the sedimentation and diffusion of these
particles and measure them and and so
what is nice about this process is that
you could actually uh uh do it in
solution and also uh count over millions
and millions of particles and so
statistic you have a statistically uh
robust uh uh idea of what your of what
your nanop particle distributions look
like now many of you have used the
analytical Ultra centrifuge to study
proteins however actually historically
the analytical Ultra centrifuge was
developed by zberg to study nanop
particles and what zberg said is is the
following if uh you know what uh uh if
you know this the the uh uh
viscosity or uh if you know the
viscosity or the density of your
solution then you you can figure out the
diameter of your of your species and its
molecular weight if and only if you know
the density of the species of the
particle so uh we can measure the
sedimentation in diffusion coefficient
with the analytic alter centrifuge and
if we know the density then we can uh
figure out uh with the spbg formulas
what is the molecular mass of the
particle and what is its uh diameter
okay but the problem is with nanop
particles we don't know what the density
is and and so and there's a density
distribution so what we need is uh a
method where we could just measure the
sedimentation and diffusion coefficients
and then obtain the density distribution
and mass and diameter all from the
analytical alra
centrifuge okay so um uh for those of
you who are not familiar with the
analytical centrifuge it typically uh uh
inside the analytical cuge you'll find
there's a rotor and normally you would
load your sample and there's there would
be a
sector that uh uh that where you load
your sample and a sector where You' load
your reference solvent and as the rotor
is rotating you would uh you would you
would have you have an optical detector
that scans the sample and reference
sector and and creates
profiles these profiles are uh recorded
over time uh and these these time
recordings are are used then are
analyzed then to obtain the size
distributions um there are many kinds of
detectors that you one can use there are
absorb there's absorbance there's
interference and there's also
fluoresence um for uh since since many
of you are uh new to this I just like to
discuss tell you a bit about how nanop
particles sediment in a gravitational
field or how just particles in general
so um a particle subjected to a
gravitational field will sediment and
will F three kinds of forces the the
first force is uh
the um centrifugation which is uh Omega
s r times the mass of the particle but
there are also two other forces one is
the uh Bucy Force which is related to
the ratio of of the particle density to
the uh uh to the solvent density
but also there's an opposing force uh
that is the frictional force which is
proportional to the frictional uh Co
coefficient of the particle times its
velocity and so uh typically the
particle reaches terminal terminal
velocity within uh micros seconds and
all these forces balance out um and then
uh if you uh sum up all the forces you
could obtain an expression that relates
molecular weight uh friction ratio and
particle density to a uh to a quantity
called
sedimentation defined as a sedimentation
coefficient which is essentially the
particle velocity divided by the
gravitational
force or the centrifugal
force um now uh if you use the Stokes
Einstein relation you could transform
you could rewrite the frictional
coefficient in terms of the diffusion uh
coefficient
and so you obtain uh the well-known one
of the well-known sbre formulas where
the molecular weight is is is equal to
sedimentation coefficient divided by the
diffusion coefficient uh times the gas
constant times temperature with related
to uh the uh density of the solvent
divided by the density of the
particle now if your uh particle is a
sphere an ideal an ideal sphere uh you
could use Stokes law uh where you could
write the diffusion coefficient in terms
of the diameter of the
particle and the viscosity of the
solution and you would get also a the
well well-known for sedb formula which
relates the diameter of the particle to
the viscosity of the solution and the
density uh of the particle and
sedimentation
constant um now if this is true uh then
you could also uh rewrite this expr
expression to write to uh to obtain a an
expression for the density of the
particle in terms of the diffusion
coefficient and sedimentation
coefficient and the viscosity of the
solvent and the viscosity of and the
density of the solvent so this is only
uh this this is only true if we know
what the shape of the particle is and
it's if it's a sphere if it's a perfect
sphere now the question uh we asked
is we know that particles nanop
particles are not perfect spheres and
they typically look like this but how
good of an approximation is it if we
assume that their uh Stoke
spheres
okay um I've uh usually when
nanoparticles sediment uh there's more
than just sedimentation force acting on
the nanop particle uh because one
creates a diffusion uh a diffusion gradi
a concentration gradient so there has to
be a diffusion flux uh created by the
sedimentation and the sum of the
diffusion force and the uh
sedimentation of the particle uh uh
leads to an equation called the lamb
equation which describes exactly how a
particle uh uh evolves or uh how the
particle sediments and moves inside a a
centrifuge uh when diffusion and uh when
subjected to uh gravitational
force okay so the term on the left is
diffus diffusive term and the term on
the right is a sedimentation
term um there's two types of major exper
kind there's two kinds of major
experiments that one can do with the
analytical centrifuge uh one of them is
called the sedimentation velocity which
is the most mostly
used method for nanop particles and uh
in this in this limit the sediment a is
much larger than the diffusion and so
the particles end up uh moving all the
way through the your your your your
sector uh and you could monitor them
over time now the other method which is
used a lot in proteins but much less
with nanop particles uh is called
sedimentation equilibrium and and in in
this case you have a uh uh you you use a
a very low sediment uh low a low uh uh
sedimentation a low gravitational force
basically you a low rotational speed in
your centrifuge and in that case the
diffusion is comparable to the
sedimentation and you get a diffusion
profile where uh at equilibrium can tell
you something about the molecular weight
uh of your of your sample but this
method is very difficult to apply with
nanop particles because nanoparticles
have a very heterogeneous is size
distribution so we're only going to deal
with right now uh with sedimentation
velocity and for most for most people
sedimentation velocity is is the way to
deal with nanop
particles um the land equation that's
used to describe nanop particles the
size the evolution of nanop particles or
anything in inside the centrifuge is is
very difficult to solve analytically and
it's typically solved through uh finite
element methods and there are good
software packages to solve them uh one
is called said fit and the other is
called Ultra scan so you could uh you
could use these after You' you do your
experiment inside the centrifuge you
collect your data you can you can take
that that data and fit it using these
either one of these software packages
and they would give you a distri uh your
uh distribution of sedimentation
coefficients and diffusion coefficients
okay and here's an example of of uh
mentation diffusion map and each one of
these hot spots in these Maps represents
a species in your sample
okay so uh you could obtain the
sedimentation and diffusion coefficients
and now we go back to this to the
question uh of solving nanoparticle
molecular weight and and density dist
and size and density
distributions um so if we appli if we
assume the particles can be treated like
a like a sphere then we could actually
uh write a uh write an expression for
the density and if we know the
sedimentation and diffusion coefficients
then we could obtain the density
distribution molecular weight
distribution and diameter distributions
okay so this is a hypothesis and uh and
so we have to prove this hypothesis and
in order to prove this hypothesis we
have to use some model
systems now uh the the best model
systems uh I found are is a class of
nanop particles called atomically
monodispersed metal clusters and there's
a lot of reports in gold and silver and
what uh separates these nanop particles
from normal nanop particle systems is
that these have a precise uh molecular
weight and a precise structure and so
they actually can be measured by X-ray
crystallography and they can be measured
by uh ma Mass spectroscopy so uh so
there so everything about them is very
well
defined and what we did is that we took
uh three sizes of the three three sizes
of well-known particles one is uh gold
25 and the other is gold 38 and the
other is gold gold 144 their sizes were
determined by mass
spectroscopy uh or X-ray defraction and
so they're very well defined and we put
them in solution and we tried measuring
them in the analytical alter
centrifuge and so we have we did this
and we could SE what's what's really
what what's really nice is that you
could separate them out and you could
detect the diffusion coefficient and
their sedimentation coefficient and uh
their uh uh diffusion sedimentation
coefficients and so as you can see all
these three hotpots correspond to each
particle um now because of that if we
use the formulas we've uh develop we've
I've shown you in the previous slid uh
then uh we could transform the
sedimentation and diffusion coefficients
into a diameter and a density and a
molecular weight now um if our formulas
are right then we'll get we'll get the
molecular weight an accurate value for
the molecular weight and what we find is
that if we compare the molecular weight
measured by Au with the molecular weight
measured by mass spectroscopy or x-ray
defraction then we get an error of less
than 5% which is uh quite good so uh
even though those particles are clearly
not uh spheres Stoke spheres uh we could
use uh The Stoke sphere approximation to
analyze these particles that have a a
low aspect
ratio and what you notice is here is
that some this is something that you
can't do with Dynamic light scattering
uh if you look at the diameter of the
particles we've measured uh they only
differ by uh fractions of a nanometer by
a few angstroms so one is so the
smallest one is
2.4 nanometers the uh the biggest one is
2.8 and so what's really uh uh uh really
advantageous about the analytical cuge
that that you you would not be able to
see in any other method uh um is that uh
these small differences in in in atomic
number can man with manifest themselves
in in in sedimentation and diffusion
coefficients um and you could do
something uh more uh with once you've
known the once you you've measured the
density and the molecular weight of the
particle using the analytical Ultra
centrifuge um you could actually uh look
at the different components of the
particles and if you if you know the
density of the different components so
for example if we know that the core is
made of gold and we know what the
density of gold is and we know that the
shell is made of some organic material
and we know what its density is then we
could actually figure out what what the
composition of the particle is so and
here we can compare the composition
obtained um just from the densities of
the
particle with the with the actual
composition obtained from Mass
spectroscopy and we see you know we're
not too bad off uh we're we're only a
few atoms off and um I'm not saying you
could use this meth method to precisely
determine the composition but you could
use it actually to tell you uh uh which
compositions are the ballpark
composition positions you're uh you
should be looking for and that's
espcially useful for people who using
mass spectroscopy because in Mass
spectroscopy there often uh uh often is
a lot of a lot of fragments and and it's
very difficult to analyze a Mass
Spectrum if you don't know what what
roughly the size of your particle
is now conversely if you know what the
formula molecular formula of your nanop
particle is from the mass spectroscopy
then you could actually use that
information to obtain density the
density of your of of of organic
material in your legum sha okay so
depending on what how much information
you have there's a lot of there's a lot
of different things you could obtain
from from just uh analyzing the density
of your particle and its total molecular
weight with the analytical alra
cuge now I I want to also uh go beyond
um uh uh atomically monodispersed
clusters and I want to show you some
some things that you would not be able
to see with uh with conventional methods
like like electromicroscopy so for
example here's a uh what seems to be a
very monodisperse size distribution of
nanop particles and they form super
luses and if you measure their size
distribution with the analytical with
the with the electron microscope you'll
see that they're about 6.7 nanometers uh
with a plusus 5 less than 5% size
distribution however when you you
analyze with the uh analytical
centrifuge you realize that there
actually is this is not one species but
in fact there's actually two
species and uh both species are very
close in size in terms of core so one is
6.8 nanometers and the other is 6.7
however what really differs between the
two species is uh one of them has much
more organic material than the other so
this is something you could not have
seen with the with uh with the electro
microscope alone
and also if you do a particle sizing
with the electron microscope uh what you
see normally is a broad size
distribution so you have many kinds of
nanop particles and you're seeing their
different
projections and however if you you you
study them with the analytical alra
centrifuge you notice that actually what
what was a broad size distribution is
actually comprised of uh individual
discrete peaks in your
sample and and so that tells you that
your sample is not a broad distribution
but in fact is composed of of uh
individual species and what you could do
actually if you do your experiment
correctly you could you could even
measure diameter and the uh density of
each uh species in solution okay now I
wouldn't uh normally if you have too
many species in solution I would not
recommend uh uh analy doing this kind of
analysis with the analytic Al centrifuge
I I would recommend first trying to
separate your species uh into uh more
monodisperse fractions for example by
density grad in centrifugation or by
improving your
synthesis now um uh okay so now I'm
going to go into the uh uh now that I've
described to you how to uh solve the
problem of the partial specific volume
I'm going to go into a general method
that was developed by recently by Boris
demler to uh to solve to to map out the
distributions of nanop particles
directly using one of the software
packages which is called Ultra scan
3 so this is the paper uh the reference
for this method and uh uh you uh a lot
of the information in the slides I'm
going to present to you are are
summarized are are show are taken from
this
paper um so if any of you have used a
software package to analyze uh uh
proteins or or uh nanop particles you'll
notice that in the analytical ultro
centrifuge the software package requires
you to input uh the partial specific
volume of your nanop particle or your
protein now this is okay for a protein
but uh because proteins have can have a
constant partial specific volume uh and
what the software package
does it uh it it it fits the diffusion
coeffic
and sedimentation coefficient in terms
of the uh uh frictional
ratio and the molecular in of of your
nanop particle or your protein so so you
get a distribution where you have a
sedimentation coefficient in terms of
the frictional ratio uh or you get a
molecular weight in terms of the
frictional ratio um however as we
remember with nanop particles you can't
do that because we don't know what the
partial specific volume is
so what Bice did is that he developed a
a uh method called the custom grid
method where uh we can we can choose
which parameter to fit to the
sedimentation and diffusion coefficient
so for example if you uh know how to
measure the partial specific volume as
in proteins and polymers through
densiometry densiometry they then you
can fit the the uh uh frictional ratio
but if you if you know the uh uh uh or
uh in the case of nanop particles you
know what the particle shape is then you
can in fact put in input the particle
shape and have the program fit the
partial specific volume or the particle
density uh or in some special cases if
you know what the molecular weight of
your particle is uh uh through Mass
spectroscopy then you could uh fit you
can fix the molecular weight and fit the
particle partic particle shape and
particle specific
volume um so um in uh in the case where
you uh you need
to uh where the molecular weight is
known uh then through Mass spectroscopy
you you you input the molecular weight
and and the program gives you uh the
partial specific volume and the uh shape
of the particle and this is this is a
this is a module in in ultr scan 3 okay
um and and so uh the here's an example
of a particle where that was that was
that was measured in the analytical
alter centrifuge and uh uh the particle
has a well-known molecular weight and um
in the if we fix the molecular weight we
could obtain the particle information
about the particle frictional ratio
which is essentially its shape and
information about its density or partial
specific volume okay and and um on the
other hand this is the more General case
where uh we typically can use electrom
microscopy to figure out what the
particle shape is or particle an an
isotropy is and and so we can fix the
particle shape and fit uh the diffusion
coefficient to the molecular weight and
particle
density and uh here one example I'm just
about to show you is the case where uh
we deal with Quant dots okay in Quantum
dots Quantum dots have a core that's
luminescent and that luminescence is
related to the particle size and so it's
very easy to figure out what the core
size is from from the uh luminescence uh
or the absorption wavelength but you
need to know for example what is the
density of the organic material in the
Shell so for example for people working
in the biomedical field conjugate uh
organic molecules or drugs to the uh
nanop particle and they want to figure
out what the density of of the organic
material that's conjugated to the nanop
particle and so uh essentially we know
that the shape of the particle is
roughly spherical so what we do is we we
analyze the particle as if it has a
fixed a fixed shape and we can uh
approximate this shape as a sphere uh so
we it would have a shape factor of equal
to
one uh and then uh you uh the uh uh we
when when you do this analysis you could
you obtain a distribution of
sedimentation coefficients versus the
partial specific volume and hence you
could uh transform this distribution uh
and create a table uh where you obtain
the uh uh different uh uh uh masses and
densities of each species of quantum
dots and then from there you could
obtain the uh uh density of the organic
component in in uh in the ligan Shell
because we uh we know what the core the
core size is from uh the absorption
Spectrum okay so um finally I'd like to
uh just describe some uh uh important
experimental considerations one should
take into account when analyzing nanop
particles So to avoid
artifacts uh and the first uh thing one
should be careful of is to choose a
proper buffer uh to dissolve their nanop
particles uh nanop particles uh need to
be colloidally stable in order to uh get
a proper measurement in in the
analytical centrifuge if you choose a a
buffer condition where the nanop
particles are not very stable then you
end up measuring uh not just the nanop
particle itself you end up measuring its
Aggregates and so it becomes the
measurement becomes very ambiguous and
it's not clear whether the Aggregates
represent an individual species or the
Aggregates represent an individual
particle so here we have a particle for
example that uh in in its most ideal
buffer is actually the individual
species however if you choose uh the
wrong buffer where this nanop particles
are not that stable then they they can
Aggregate and you would see that
aggregation uh however uh uh in this
case we know that the nanop particles
monodispersed so we know that
uh the the aggregation is an artifact of
of the wrong selection of a buffer but
in many cases we don't have this uh the
luxury so we have to try different
buffers to make sure that the samples
are colloidally stable so you would have
to try your measure your sample in
different buffer conditions uh just to
check the size distrib if the size
distribution changes or not the second
consideration is that concentration so
typically uh you would like to select a
concentration range where your nanop
particles don't interact a lot okay so
if you choose a uh here's for example a
nanoparticle concentration nanoparticles
measure same nanoparticles measured at
three different concentrations and uh if
you choose a concentration range where
the nanop particles interact a lot then
uh you will get a non ideal
sedimentation and you'll also get a size
distribution or sedimentation
coefficient distribution that's not
represent of your nanop particle so
ideally when you measure your nanop
particles try to measure them at three
different concentrations that high
concentration middle concentration and
and a very low
concentration okay the uh final
consideration uh I'd like to this is
something that you know you one hardly
observes in in in uh proteins but it's
very common with uh nanop particles um
now the the sectors that that where you
load the nanop particles in are made of
made of can be made of three typically
three kinds of materials uh either a
charcoal epon material which is kind of
a a polymer uh or uh aluminum or
titanium now ideally you would like to
use the uh charcoal polymer because it
interacts the least with nanop particles
uh however you have to keep in mind you
know most nanoparticle systems are are
run uh are not just run in water they're
run in organic uh solvents which can
destroy the uh uh centerpiece so uh so
then you you're left with uh trying
either the aluminum centerpiece or the
titanium centerpiece and and often you
have to check first whether your nanop
particles react to the centerpiece or
not so you could see on the left hand
side a comparison of the same nanop
particle running Titanium or aluminum
centerpiece and you would see that for
example the nanoparticle reacts with the
aluminum centerpiece more than the
titanium that's not a general a case but
you would have to uh uh try the
different centerpieces to check uh uh
whether your nanop particles are stable
so what I would do is I would put the
the nanoparticle solution inside the
central piece and I would check its
absorbance over time whether this nanop
particle stays stable or not if the
absorbance changes over time then that's
a good sign that's a a good sign that uh
that it's that it's not stable and you
have to find either conditions where the
nanoparticles are stable or uh a
centerpiece that uh stabilizes that that
doesn't react to their nanop particles
so typically uh you have to remember
with metal nanop particles uh things
like aluminum can can react can
galvanically exchange with uh uh with
the nanop particle so
all right um I in summary I'd like to
summarize this talk by saying uh the
main points is that you could
measure simultaneously size density and
molecular weight distributions of nanop
particles using the analytical
centrifuge when you if you know what the
frictional ratio is and and through some
some method uh other method like
electron microscopy or x-ray
defraction um you
uh you could distinguish between
particles that differ in in diameter by
a few angstroms using the analytical Str
fuge that's one advantage you would not
find with any other method and and
what's really beautiful about it is that
you could do this in solution in the in
the native state of your nanop
particle um and then I'd like to say
that a lot of times uh to to our
surprise you could estimate uh uh very
uh many nanop particles are sto spheres
especially if they have very small
aspect
ratios um and then uh finally I'd like
to say that you could obtain information
about the organic component in the nanop
particle uh if you know something about
the core through other methods such as
electromicroscopy or uh or through uh or
or beforehand you know what the density
of the core
is um I'd like to clude this talk by
thanking my collaborators uh Boris
demler and his group Gary gbit Virgil
Sheriff at the University of Texas
Health Science Center in San Antonio and
uh Randy Carney and Francisco stachi at
epfl and tick Lam nean and Paul Mia at
University of Melbourne um thank you for
listening to me and uh I'm open for
questions thank you Dr barlar um it was
very very informative talk and uh you
are clearly a Pioneer in the field we've
received uh very good questions um from
our
audience um especially a couple
questions about aggregation so uh
Victoria verdor asked how do you deal
with nanoparticles that have a high
tendency to aggregate in
solution okay that's a very good
question so the fir my my first answer
is that uh you need to find a buffer
where they or Sol or or a solvent that
minimizes the aggregation as much as
possible and uh the second second thing
you need to do is basically you you have
to use a uh uh a preparative centrifuge
to uh get rid of the Aggregates uh
before you run the your sample and the
third thing I would do is also run the
sample at the lowest possible
concentration um uh that you can and and
this is how you would minimize uh a
aggregation as much as possible um it is
a big problem but it's something but but
this is but this is how you would M
mitigate
it great yes thank you uh that's those
are some great suggestions um Alexandra
lroy um asked if you functionalize the
particle with a biomolecule or drug how
well can you characterize your system
could you determine the Lian density and
distribution of your particles relative
to the naked
nanoparticle um yes uh you can um what
you need to know uh actually uh you need
to know uh uh first of all you need to
know what your particle is what what
your particle looks like before uh
you've conjugated it uh so you need to
uh measure your particle in the centri
fuge before
conjugation and then you would measure
it after uh conjug ation and uh it would
be also good if you can uh figure out
approximately what the core something
about the core diameter through a method
like electron microscopy because then
you could combine that information and
uh you could obtain very quantitative uh
data about um uh about measuring uh the
the uh uh Lian density um there is
actually a paper I guess in 20 9 or 2008
um that was I get by malan's group uh
where they actually uh do do try to
address that question and uh you will
also address this question in in uh both
uh the paper we have in nature
Communications and the paper that was
published by uh in analytical Chemistry
by Boris demler um so yes you you uh you
can actually use this method
um uh as long as
your uh I would say I would as long as
your what you use to conjugate is uh not
uh does not significantly change the
shape the overall shape of your particle
so you know if you have a particle
that's a few nanometers and you
conjugate to something that's 100
nanometers then then I wouldn't advise
to do that but if you're you have a
particle that's that's uh uh uh if your
conjugate is on the order
or or comparable in size to the uh your
particle then this is a very useful
method to
do yes great thanks um and we are
continuing to receive U questions um and
we will try to get to as many as can as
we as we can um a question from Assad
Kim out of the University of Karachi um
was wondering whether or not you can use
Au um for liposome uh nanop particles
um in so uh that's that's a good qu good
question I I have not tried it uh in in
person but I think in in principle uh it
should be it should be possible it
should be as long as you could detect
the liposomes with the uh with with one
of your one of the optical detectors on
the analytical alter centrifuge uh uh
should be okay and the other thing is
you know they should the liposomes
should be
uh relatively uh stable so they
shouldn't shouldn't be uh dynamically
changing during the experiment I mean
you uh you could you could get some
interesting information in the
analytical Al centrifuge by monitoring
this Dynamic change but you cannot get
information about the size distribution
of the liposomes if you if if they're
changing during the experiment
okay um yes second question or next
question
another follow-up question I guess we're
getting a lot of questions on different
types of nanop particles um if you could
just comment uh I know we we've already
talked about liposomes but uh uh it
seems people are asking questions about
other biological nanoparticles as well
as say nanor rods could you just make a
general comment yes on so how Au is able
to characterize all these different
that's a good question so uh things like
nanor rods and Sh you uh you need to ask
you need to uh in order to to get you
can always get very very good actually
qualitative data from the analytical OB
fuge even if you don't know anything
about the density or uh or the particle
shape uh however for things like uh rods
you you you need to use uh you need to
estimate what the particle shape is and
estimate what the particle uh even for
other any other molecule that has a that
have that have very large aspect ratios
you need to figure out what what is the
um the frictional ratio for that
specific side for that specific shape
and there are actually programs uh
developed by the uh uh centrifugation
community and there are actually also
analytical formulas that can give you
the frictional ratio for a given shape
and so once you know what the shape is
you could use the custom grid method uh
in in Ultra scan 3 and you could input
the
uh shape particle shape uh and it would
fit the the the would it would um uh the
program would fit the particle density
or partial specific volume and molecular
weight based on the shape you've given
uh the only I would say the only uh the
only uh thing that would uh um constrain
this method is that if you have also a
distribution in particle shapes so uh uh
then your problem becomes very difficult
to analyze you have to either have uh a
fixed particle shape or a fixed uh
density if you have either one then the
system can be analyzed quantitatively
but if you have if you have both
hetrogeneous size and hetrogeneous
density and Het hetrogeneous shape then
uh you you will not be able to get uh
quantitative data from the analytical
uture next question thank you um another
question and it brings up a good point
uh from Anatoli andreco um asked if you
calibrate the system does a require any
type of
Standards uh good question so this is
one of the great aoc's strongest Point
AOC is a uh first principle method it it
does not require any calibration at all
no calibration nothing it's a uh the
theory behind a see all the equations
are derived from from uh first principle
thermodynamic equations and so um you
know all you need to do in the Au is
make sure you're measuring you're uh
you're measuring your your sample at a
fixed uh temperature and you know the
viscosity and density of your solvents
and all these are actually very easy and
straightforward to do um so you don't
need any any unlike any other method uh
most other methods like mography or G
electropheresis or uh the Au does not
require any uh standard it's an absolute
method great thank you a very good very
good point there um a followup on that
uh by Robert weton from the University
of Texas he um brought up the point that
there are other methods such as
chromatography and electrophoretic
Mobility um for particle size analysis
um how would you compare the results as
far as accuracy obtained by these
methods compared to
Au okay um in uh okay that's that's a
very good question and uh uh in in terms
of Separation uh you know the ability to
separate different species I think uh uh
uh Electro electroforesis and uh uh and
Au are are comparable in terms of being
able to separate species how uh however
um in chromatography is also reasonably
okay uh however uh Au is is a much more
General method because it
R unlike for example uh chromatography
or Au you don't need any specific
interaction uh so for example in in in
in in electroforesis you need the
particles to be charged and typically
you need an aquous uh solvent in order
to run your sample uh for chromatography
you need uh some sort of interaction
between your uh stationary phase and the
particle and and this is not a something
uh it's not something uh uh trivial to
do while in in AU uh the particle all
you need is your particles to be stable
in solution and uh uh and the solvent
can be almost anything any solv or the
organic or in solvent or aquous
Solutions the and the separation is not
is related only to mass and density and
so it's a more in in my opinion it's a
they they all offer uh uh uh different
especially electri foris offers
information on on the charge uh but but
as a as a separation method
uh uh Au is is much more General separ
ation method but also with electris you
uh you need standards while in AU you
don't need the standard to measure the
size of your of your
material and with chromatography you
typically need a standard as
well okay thank you um we'll get to one
more question before the end of the hour
um nicolay
kosov asked uh the size range of nanop
particles uh using using
AU okay um that's a a good question so
um Au uh in in theory Au works on nanop
particles of all sizes um the uh however
you know a big part so particles
particles that are very big they
sediment very quickly and and uh the uh
they require very low uh rotational
speeds the actual instrument uh is
limited to about 3,000 RPMs and so uh
that means that uh uh particles that are
typically
bigger uh that are uh bigger than than
than a few hundreds of nanometers are
are are a bit challenging to measure
with the Au because they sediment uh
very quickly uh but it's not a challenge
that cannot be solved you you would you
would you would have to do is increase
the viscosity of your solution so that
it it allows you to uh uh the particles
to sediment slowly even at a high
gravitational field so a is is actually
the smaller the particle the easier the
method is but I think for particles that
range from 1 to 20 nanometers you know
it's it's quite ideal uh above that size
uh you you're still it's still very good
very easy but I think you would still
you you would have to consider uh
increasing the viscosity of your solvent
uh in order to get enough data points uh
for your uh measurement but in general
it works for uh particles of all sizes
um it all depends on how long uh the
particles take to sediment uh inside the
inside the
centrifuge very good um at this time I
would just like to again thank Dr Osman
bakar uh for providing a very
informative talk on um how good Au can
characterize particles and I would also
like to thank everybody in attendance of
this webinar
series uh at this time we will log off
and um we appreciate uh your attendance
thank
you thank you very
much